the leader of al-Qaeda Iman al-zawahari
has been killed in a U.S drone strike in
Afghanistan over the weekend in a
televised address U.S President Joe
Biden said intelligence officials
tracked zohahari to a home in downtown
Kabul where he was hiding with his
family Biden approved the operation last
week savari's death eliminates the
figure who shaped Al-Qaeda more than
anyone first as Osama Bin Laden's Deputy
since 1998 and then his successor
well this video purportedly shows the
aftermath of the strike in Kabul which
killed zawahari on the weekend the
Afghan interior Ministry denied reports
on social media about the Drone strike
from hiding he coordinated Al qaeda's
branches and all around the world
including setting priorities for
providing operational guidance that call
for and inspired attacks against U.S
targets he made videos including the
recent weeks calling for his followers
to attack the United States and our
allies
now
justice has been delivered and this
terrorist leader is no more
well Muhammad jamjun has more now on the
man who was al-qaeda's second most
prominent figure after Osama bin Laden
had long been a deputy to Osama Bin
Laden but after the U.S killing of the
then Al-Qaeda leader in 2011 sawah took
charge of the Armed group
attempting to expand its reach while
never engendering the kind of loyalty
afforded his predecessor while he did
inherit the uh the mantle of leadership
he did not inherit Osama Bin Laden's
legitimacy as a mujahid leader or his uh
credibility and legitimacy on Charisma
amongst the various mujahideen groups
born in Egypt in 1951 zawahari came from
a distinguished family studied medicine
and became a surgeon in 1973 he joined
the Egyptian Islamic Jihad group
the assassination of President Anwar
Sadat in 1981 for which the group was
blamed proved to be a turning point for
zawahiri while he was not charged in
connection with Sadat's killing he was
imprisoned on conspiracy charges one of
thousands of religious activists jailed
and tortured after the assassination
many analysts say that experience would
eventually lead him to violence
after his release from prison zawahari
left Egypt for Peshawar in Pakistan
where he worked as a doctor treating
Afghan Fighters then it was on to
Afghanistan where he fought against the
Soviet occupation and where he began his
partnership with Bin Laden within a few
years both men would become part of the
core group that became Al-Qaeda under
their leadership the armed group accused
the west of waging a modern day Crusade
against Muslims and set as its ultimate
goal the establishment of Islamic rule
throughout the world al-qaeda's ideology
along with its International Campaign Of
Violence culminated in the 9 11 attacks
Washington offered a reward of 25
million dollars to bring zawadi to
Justice offshoot to the armed group in
Yemen Somalia and Algeria are widely
believed to be his work after when Osama
Bin Laden was assassinated and amen you
can see the fracturing of the
organization becoming more and more
apparent
once the Syrian Civil War began sawahari
found that al-qaeda's dominance was
being increasingly challenged by isil
which had carved out territory for
itself in Iraq Syria and Libya and had
fighters in Yemen in 2016 sawari urged
Afghan fighters to Rally around the
Taliban and reject isil's branch in
Afghanistan the U.S had long insisted
there's a relationship between the
Taliban and Al-Qaeda but Taliban leaders
have denied that
I call upon the brotherly Muslims and
jihadis in general and in Afghanistan in
particular to get behind the Jihadi the
patient and the steadfast Emirate and
not to respond to the calls aimed at
dividing the ranks of jihadis the death
of amen and zawahari brings an end to
one of the most turbulent times in
recent International Security the world
will now be watching to see how Al-Qaeda
handles the death of its second
prominent leader
well Dave deroche is a senior fellow at
the gulf International Forum he says the
fact that al-qaeda's leader was killed
in Kabul suggests Afghanistan's
government is protecting armed groups
this is embarrassment it shows that
um Al-Qaeda has found a safe haven in
the taliban's Afghanistan just as they
did before 9 11 and it basically puts
the lie to any idea that they have
changed from what they were as if you
know the proof of repression of women is
mentioned in the economy uh you know as
if any proof were needed the Taliban is
what they've always been and they are
affiliated with Al Qaeda and other
terrorist groups the problem is this
happened in downtown Kabul in a house
owned by a prominent leader in the
Taliban and so what it does is it
highlights the fact that you know the
low point of Biden's presidency which
was the uh
unseemly uh withdrawal from Afghanistan
it highlights the fact that that
basically handed over uh Afghanistan to
a movement that is hostile to the United
States so you know he he has a moment of
Triumph and I'm sure he will try to make
the most of it but unfortunately
um the the question is so what exactly
was he doing there and why was he there
and how was he able to be there and why
is the government in Afghanistan
supporting zawahari those are all
embarrassing questions for Biden that
hearkens back to the low point of his
presidency